vous l'aimez pas Renault là oh non mais
il a l'impression que vous l'aimez pas
dire
voici maintenant les Garçons Bouchers
des indies dans le showbiz y'a pas écrit
pigeon nous on passera après ça au blind
test il se laisse mais on tente autour
du top 5 ans les Garçons Bouchers vous
êtes devenus les plus médiatiques des
alternatives des plus showbises de tous
les Indes maintenant c'est pas chiant ça
veut dire
chemise
vous êtes les plus officiels des
marginaux si vous préférez mais ça fait
trois exemples que je vous donne à mon
avis vous devez avoir compris
on a de la bière on a de la lumière ça
marche
à la télé pour faire la promo de votre
nouveau 45 on fait comme à la télé là
alors bon nous allons voir 5 45 ronds
aussi et avec deux faces alors sur la
première il y a quoi il y a une reprise
de nommé de poulet qui se transforme en
du Beaujolais pour oublier la nuit est
parti Mary pourquoi vous faites tout le
temps des covers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est venu dans l'émission on avait
l'impression qu'il savait que vous
l'aimiez pas pourquoi je sais pas qu'on
l'aime pas c'est plutôt qu'on le déteste
mais
voilà boucherie production maintenant
parlons business donc musidis vous avez
laissé tomber pourquoi
c'était la fin de contrat qu'on aime le
changement et que on nous proposait
mieux
vous êtes fier
ça s'est passé comment il nous a vu à la
télévision justement à quoi ça sert à
grand chose c'est important la
télévision anglaise et puis il a trouvé
ça bien là il a voulu signer un garçon
boucher mais comme on lui a dit que nous
aussi on avait notre compagnie de disque
comme lui fallait prendre tout le monde
ou prendre personne donc il a préféré
prendre tout le monde enfin bon coup
voilà c'est devenu un businessman
maintenant
tirer par Virgin ouais enfin bon on a
quand même revendu un sacré paquet
de la bière
mais en fait les labelins dès le
problème c'est qu'on se fait piquer les
disons que on a certainement
quoi
on va devenir des requins vis-à-vis des
majeurs
à nous donc ça vous fait pas chier de
venir des businessman et requins des
marginaux officiels enfin tout va bien
être businessman c'est pouvoir
bouffer la laine sur le dos des majors
et faire une meilleure travail avec les
groupes vous voyez à ce moment-là pour
lancer comme ça et le truc de Jacques
Lang là vous y allez au cours de
management là parce qu'il paraît qu'il
donne des cours de management c'est pas
mal le problème c'est que il a dit quoi
dans la jungle il y a pas de salle pour
tourner donc ça sert à rien
à force de jouer en plein air qu'est-ce
que tu en penses
du fait que le gouvernement s'occupe du
rock'n'roll je trouve ça normal quoi ça
dépend c'est c'est à partir du moment où
c'est une reconnaissance je vois pas
pourquoi on finirait des sommes
colossales la musique contemporaine dans
la danse classique et tu le retiendras
qui musique populaire
quand même
c'est le premier quoi parce que jusqu'à
présent dans l'histoire du rock n' roll
on peut pas dire que il y en a eu des
tonnes c'est ton jamais les Beatles on
vient failli avoir le MBE vous avez pas
peur de cautionner des hommes politiques
non
ben non parce que nous on considère que
nous on est pour ceux qui veulent de
l'argent
de droite on aurait eu que dalle donc
on va partir
maintenant ils ont changé mon conseil
maintenant ils ont dit des choses on
attend de voir
attends de voir les résultats quoi mais
bon parler c'est bien s'il y a pas de
résultats on sera les premiers lieux et
qu'il y en a pas s'il y a pas de thunes
vous allez hurler bon vous êtes prêts
pour le blind test
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est parti
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est qui porte mentale
[Musique]
bravo
[Applaudissements]
ah il est fort vous avez bien fait les
amener les deux là hein ouais ça c'est
le footballeur c'est Jean-Pierre
François je te jure
c'est tellement beau
quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous allez vous faire huer comme des
minable
[Musique]
pour les énerver encore
c'est le même esprit si tu veux
[Musique]
ils sont tous pareils
[Applaudissements]
il y a pas que les grands
qui pleurent il y a pas que les gens qui
rêvent
François
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emmanuels
c'est Patrick brouette
la fontaine
[Applaudissements]
ça m'étonnerait qu'il fasse partie du
groupe longtemps
un mec qui reconnaît mélodie
[Applaudissements]
bravo
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
YouTube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu